hallo leute herzlich willkommen von
kommen
wir sind heute im wunderschönen norwegen
genau genommen auf der insel kuba und
wenn heute unterwegs und max hatte max
hallo kommst du her aus kiel aus kiel
aber du lebst jetzt in mohring seit 23
jahren
und was ist dein beruf mag ja ich bin
möbeltischler und der bootsbauer
akademischen grad in ökonomie und bin
seit freitag letzter woche offiziell
lehre aber du bist ja kein normaler
steht wenn ich im kleinen raum was was
dann lehrerin ein landschulheim in
meiner kindheit in deutschland gab es
nicht mehr
norwegen haben alle die in dem jahr
zwölf jahre alt wenn die angelegenheit
ausdruck auf dem landschulheim das
entweder in den bergen ist oder wie vor
mehr und da lernen die schüler zwischen
regel alles was mit den maritime
tradition zu tun hat nach möglichkeit ja
zurück in die natur
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wir fahren jetzt raus das vergesse nicht
ganz klar wie sich das mit dem wind
verhält wir haben ja nordwind er war
ganz ziemlich stramm jetzt ist er fast
auf null runter sollte auch süden drehen
und da muss mir dann zusehen dass wir
ein platz finden wo wir in jedem fall
rankommen gesehen jetzt haben wir ja das
ist ja gar nicht optimal für uns die
roten dinger im wasser das sind die
letzten bilder für die krabben die
beiden hier unter unseren netzen sind um
die ecke und so werden die schüler in
norwegen unterrichtet im landschulheim
aufgebot
[Musik]
oder wird das netz eingeholt ein
ziemlich langes netz
bisher wurde noch kein fisch gesichtet
sein blauer fuß drin
einzig ein ganz typischer tier gefangen
ja ganzen blaue sehr schön
er war also mindestens 20 punkte während
man sich was ihr an den kriegen eine
gute ausbeute will noch sagen also wenn
wir überlegen sind sechs leute hier im
boot und alle sollten davon essen dann
kannst du hoffen dass ein scharfes
messer dabei hatten wir einen platz zu
sichern also sofern sie nicht mit
gandalf und europa wolle aber nicht
essen oder eine art von unterricht in
deutschland auch sagen ob das in euren
ländern gibt fahrt ihr auch mit einer
schulklasse rauf auf mehr
5 zwischen und lärmt alles über die
natur wir sind dann die vorurteile die
man hat die nicht stimmen
die kinder komm raus und glauben dass
das was der so aussieht das ist immer so
das ist im meer fische geht das das ist
eigentlich zur disposition steht und in
der meisten zeit des jahres ist einfach
so dass für gäste sind hier draußen und
ab und zu zur not gelitten die gäste und
ab und zu hat ist einfach super hier
nichts zu suchen
es sind einfach kräfte die wir nicht
wieder beherrschen noch kontrollieren
noch in einer form und muss man eben
auch mit denen man muss zu hause sein
und das ist eine sache die verschwindet
mehr und mehr glauben wenn alles muss
zugänglich sein für jeder tages und
nachtzeit eines menschen und das auf die
technikgläubigkeit die merkt man schnell
außerdem ist die frage wie groß sie
wählen werden bevor das gefühl dass
jedes boot wird klein was wir werden
jetzt klappen käfige hoch oder der
eingelegt haben herwig haben tätig
reingeholt oder etwa war drin
pauli
ich bin ja mist oder krabbelt ein
bisschen angst vor den dingen wird ein
guter fang doch zwischendurch sind wir
ja soll ich anfangen als wären wir
ungefähr bis zu 60 haben gehabt wird
bisschen dass ihr was zwischen 20 und 30
15 was macht er jetzt mit den kampf die
wir heute haben gekocht und gegessen
werden die kinder den kurs kriegen wie
man die da rauskriegt heute ist es meine
aufgabe die kochen knacken und
vorzubereiten
man kann ja will gerne da mal probieren
noch nicht probiert hat publisher gerne
mache das gerne wir hoffen wir dass die
kinder das nicht mögen
warum oder müssen wir erwachsenen zu oft
verloren und dort aushelfen
wir müssen anliegen alles perfekt alle
müssen sind die felder auf wunderschönen
das hier ist das ist quasi der hafen der
insel das alles hier die ganzen in
welten haben und hier ist das
landschulheim kommen hier das stehen die
eltern schüler diesen gerade erst
aufgewacht stehen am fenster und freuen
sich über den frischen fisch den wir
gefangen haben in einem max macht etwas
bot fest mit dem kauf dann werden hier
die krabben von bord gebracht und dann
sehen wir zu wie er das mit den schülern
verarbeitet dass wenn er auch wenn
gespannt das ist der eine fuß den wir
gefangen haben es wunderschön lippen
lippen fish hat 21 bis zu 21 zum teil
giftigen stachel hinten
also bringen jetzt den fisch in den
äußert lebt ihr noch bewegte die die
flossen das ist ein gutes zeichen und
ist die frage ob er die clean bewegt das
ist die zweite unter wenn er das tut ist
das eine gute chance dass er überlebt
das ist ein segel auf der fasnet wieder
warum willst du die denn jetzt wieder
einmal da ist zu wenig fleisch wenn
sowas würde ich wieder rausschmeißen
du siehst die dunkle kannte hier und die
dunkle kannte hier auch die haben gerade
vor kurzer zeit erst ihren panzer
gewechselt und haben circa ein drittel
das körper dazu gelegt das heißt aber
dass am fleisch ist nur das drin was er
vorhatte
entsprechend klein das heißt da ist hier
im prinzip nur luft werden wenn ich
jetzt müssen wir kraft benutzt würde
dann könnte ich den wie ein rohes ei
verknappen
den holen wir den nächsten herz wenn er
dann die konzerte
[Gelächter]
sieben stunden später ist es
mittlerweile 15 uhr
wir sind zurück beim ein landschulheim
und hier sehen wir die max mit den
schülern die kamen und den fisch
zubereiten wird dann gucke mal rein
jetzt werden die krabben in die küche
gebracht werden
hier in der küche wünsche und zwei töpfe
mit kochendem wasser bereit ich
befürchte das schlimmste
als erstes kommt erst mal eine richtige
prise weiß in den top reihen und die
kranken stehen darunter max werden die
iss leben gekommen ich werde ihn gekocht
das ist wichtig das krabbeln wenn du dir
aus münster city am lehnte die
entwickeln eine relativ schnelle giftige
stoffe die sich unheimlich und eine
fischvergiftung sehr bekannte sehr
beliebt geht weg frei die wir haben
werden immer ein leben lang gelähmt
gekocht wobei die aussehen als wenn sie
an von schlag zu werden also keine kraft
mehr haben dann kommen die nicht mehr
verändert nicht unnötig schmerzen die
kochen sie sind hier so toll aber wenn
du eine kuh geschieht zum beispiel im
kopf hast auch motive das sind dann die
nerven die sich noch diese graben hand
geschaffen die kosten nicht mehr in den
kochtopf sie werden jetzt wieder ins
meer geschmissen
diese kamen haben überlebt sie passten
nicht mehr den kopf frei
deswegen werden wir jetzt wieder etwas
angeschnitten und gesehen da unten hatte
eine kleine klappen kolonie am grund des
hafens an geregelt so wenn die denn
aufwendige kochen das erste was uns
auffällt ist dass die farbe sie gerne in
rot es gibt verschiedene methoden zu
machen wenn du unterwegs bist du das was
du hast einen stein oder wenn du in
norwegen gibt spezialwerkzeug für sowas
eine kleine zange und eine großen
nussknacker
ich probiere das lammfleisch dass eine
delikatesse
das schmeckt richtig lecker das ist süß
und lecker
[Gelächter]
höhere liebe zuschauer jetzt sind die
karten auf dem tisch und wir sind am
ende unserer sendung angelangt max
danken es uns eingeladen hat wir
brauchen bevor mögen uns sehr gefreut
wenn wir raus zu fahren zu sehen wie er
die das essen zubereitet und mit den
schülern zusammen arbeitet und wir
werden dadurch auch gefallen schreibt
uns doch mal in die kommentare
wie das bei euch abläuft habt ihr auch
gepasst wie eine landschulheim wo ihr
etwas lernt über die natur norden gärung
geschossen ländern dass wir uns mal
interessieren oder wie lernt ihr in
euren schule über die natur und wenn ihr
lust hat noch mit kabeln und übungen zu
bekommen dann werden unbedingt ein
mitglied bei uns das könnte hier werden
und abonniert unseren kanal
was können wir da machen danke zu sagen
sie zum der gemäß
[Musik]